hello for speed i am liang jili and i'm
here to answer the question like 30 30
questions in three minutes i'm sorry
that i can't speak english just saying
any words spit anything everything
i'm sweating
[Music]
keep the speed
oh sorry
don't you care because i like the freaky
nasty sexy and talented girl
oh emotional oranges west coast love
jukebox on the blacktop that's how west
coast
maybe i'm the loudest one in this room
time's going tommy's going tommy's
taking
creativity he equals muscle
i think i might be the maximum
drive-through cashier or something like
loud and using my voice and
confusing people
i have a two chomp you have a finger you
gotta go like this
elephant
that guy my company boasts who's pay me
always give me the good money good meals
also he's my best friend so sorry mom
from coco the movie disney movie you
always have to seize the moment like
this buzzfeed
okay we got the honey
a little asmr
so hungry
lay down my bed just feel useless
zero coke after the sweet potato
oh
chipotle i think that is god's favorite
masterpiece bring it to korea please
20 pieces of salami and four pieces of
tofu
big mouth confidence
oh my gosh i have a crush on rapper lei
one and i make a song with
him i'm not to see this thing huh that's
the biggest flags in my life shout my
feelings to him i love you
be my fiancee and he was like no exactly
no then i'll make the song
my voice literally my biggest
[Music]
face like oh
please face and avocado because they
look so silly and dumb like me
[Music]
when i meet them in this on the streets
they always following like oh my gosh
why are you following
because i want to take a picture with
you yes like this
one day
i can't compete with
kendrick lam or big shock
better than avocado pizza
two minutes of hot water five minutes of
coconut two minutes five minutes two
five four three
i always wearing like sengwa hamburg i
think i might be impressed by chongya
keep going bro but eat less please
confidence girl
two plus two is four minus one is three
quick math big shock
four plus boys eight minus three is five
quick math
that that that dumped me korea is five
am right now
he's not christian but
pick up pick up pick up
i'm done with it
dreams comes true buzzfeed thank you
don't block me this video shouldn't be
on youtube
i screw them i need to leave this is
chaos